es temporada de siembra sin embargo sus
cultivos están amenazados por las ventas
este es el campo de trigo digo un
agricultor ucraniano de 60 años
allí cayó un cohete sin explotar y
vimos el proyectil hacia algún tiempo
no tocamos esta parte del campo tenemos
que seguir adelante porque no podemos
detener el proceso de cultivo de la
tierra te informamos a las autoridades
estamos esperando nuestro turno para
desactivarlo por qué
los campesinos ucranianos se han visto
obligados a estar en la primera línea en
esta guerra bajo minas proyectiles y
cohetes sin detonar
los agricultores debemos trabajar
durante la guerra porque somos nosotros
quienes damos seguridad alimentaria al
estado
si no plantamos los cultivos no
tendremos cosecha y ya ven lo que está
pasando en nuestro país los rusos se han
llevado la mitad de nuestras cosechas
a metros del campo de igor
se realizan los trabajos de desminado
estos artículos pueden contener
detonadores con dispositivos de
autodestrucción eso significa que una
persona puede seguir trabajando y como
no ha explotado su detonador sigue
encendido puede explotar en cualquier
momento y herir a las personas
invasión ruso ucrania ha generado un
aumento en los precios de los alimentos
a nivel mundial que se debe a que gran
parte del trigo el maíz y cebada que
requiere el mundo están atrapadas en la
guerra rusia y ucrania generan el 30 por
ciento de las exportaciones mundiales de
trigo rusia además produce casi el 25
por ciento del potasio y el fosfato
precedentes de los fertilizantes
necesarios para los cultivos de a nivel
mundial la escasez de estos productos ha
hecho que los precios se disparen desde
el inicio de la invasión rusa los
precios del trigo han aumentado un 21
por ciento los de la cebada un 33 por
ciento y de algunos fertilizantes un 40
por ciento